j'ai entendu parler de la boxe arabe non
tu connais pas la boxe arabes regardent
souvenir c'est de l'info si c'est de
l'intox regarde
nuit de printemps à sartrouville au mois
de mars 1991 des émeutes éclatent
bilan un mort un jeune beur même chose à
mantes-la-jolie un mois plus tard la
banlieue s'enflamme un autre jeune beur
et tué ainsi qu'une femme policier les
dégâts matériels sont considérables mais
le 7 novembre alors que toute vie
collective a cessé à mantes-la-jolie une
association locale décide de relever le
gant
elle organise un championnat du monde de
boxe arabe une discipline créée en 1985
par un tunisien hédi sediri la
manifestation réunit 1500 spectateurs
c'est un énorme succès la boxe arabe
constituer en fédération internationale
a fait son apparition dans la banlieue
et travailleurs sociaux apprécié pour
eux c'est une voie vers l'intégration
on est une association qui travaille
entre autres sur l'insertion des jeunes
ici il ya beaucoup de maghrébins qui se
retrouvent dans la boxe arabe
d'autant plus que le champion du monde
est tunisien un soupçon de boxe anglaise
un zeste de boxe française
deux figures de boxe thaï et de
kickboxing la boxe arabes se pratique
pieds nus elle autorise coup de genou
coup de tibia et projections la
fédération de boxe française n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions
comme le ministère de la jeunesse et des
sports elle ne reconnaît pas la boxe
arabe mais eddy sediri s'accroche c'est
pas une bourse qui vient d'adapter arabe
mais les parent m'a rappelé je suis fier
quoi c'est un sport avec ses règles qui
imposent une maîtrise qui permet une
utilisation positive de son énergie
ce qui est bon pour un début de travail
d'insertion et d'un petit groupe qui va
qui va s'exprimer sous cette forme de
boxe de sportive mais ça ne sera pas du
tout représentatif de notre musique
ce serait souhaitable c'est que c'est à
dire non seulement les arabes mais
également d'autres personnes pourquoi
pas la boxe luxembourgeoise la boxe
suisse et pourquoi pas ceci dit il ya
quelque chose de positif l'agressivité
et canonisé c'est toute cette énergie
dont il déborde bien ils peuvent comme
ça se libérer complètement et devenir
très calme ouais
est-ce de l'info s de l'intox
vincent van gogh à toi de jouer info
info
pourrais tu dis ça je sais chou alors
pourquoi pas fréquent c'est foutu
d'accord et toi ça j'adore
et moi je crois que c'est de l'info
parce que c'est pas de me rendre dès
canaliser la violence dans ce qu'il ya
de plus noble dans l'ombre la boxe
d'accord et toi qui me lis un texte il
m'a dit intense alors on sait pas on
écoute l'expert philippe gas bravo
d'abord que j'ai préparé un long texte
de commentaires assez précis pour vous
expliquer exactement les tenants et les
aboutissants de la boxe non j'ai pas
grand chose à dire finalement non j'ai
réfléchi non thierry finalement je
manquais rivasi tu peux tu as peut-être
un commentaire toi thierry non non moi
je n'ai qu'une idée le score non ça fait
3 2 que la météo c'est dany teganya
c'est toi les toitures de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu